here with reaction fox news contributor
laura trump along with fox news
contributor joe concha
let's start laura your reaction to
senator tim scott which i
found repulsive
uh well it's absolutely ridiculous i
mean some of the commentary you heard
there
is in and of itself racist how about the
fact that maybe the republican party
chose tim scott to deliver this message
because he was
well equipped to do so he's an
intelligent individual
he's a well-respected senator within our
party yet of course they defer
immediately to race because that is all
they know and by the way
joe biden if you say that you don't
believe that this is a racist country
then i guess
we'll be hearing you condemning black
lives matter
i guess you're going to come out and say
that you no longer believe
in critical race theory being taught in
our schools 1619 project
critical race theory teaches people and
our children
to judge one another not based on the
content of their character
but solely on the color of their skin it
would have our children
growing up hating this country and
hating one another because they do not
look alike
it is absolutely disgusting but this is
again it's it's part of what the
democrats do they always turn
what they're doing and they try to say
republicans are doing it
what a disgusting display that was joe
contra i've complimented you before i
i think you are probably the best
informed
uh student and columnist on the media
you deserve your own media show here on
fox by the way you do such a good job
and i honestly you've been watching the
media all these years
you ever see anything quite this bad the
fact that in this day and age of
cancer culture woke america that you can
say the things that were said about
senator scott
well first of all sean thanks for the
kind words clearly you have venmo and
clearly you got that payment that i sent
you earlier for that introduction so
thank you
for that i appreciate it i don't take
compliments well i'm sorry uh
look i i want to go to that biden
interview
and i'll answer your question by just
giving a small example
as far as what we saw with him on nbc
with craig
melvin and how to push back when the
president makes such a ridiculous claim
so biden said that if he was closer than
six feet during that interview
he would put his mass back on so i would
say if i were in melvin's position
okay mr president you're vaccinated
correct yes okay i'm vaccinated right
yes the vaccines work right yes
so why do you have to put a mass back on
if
all those things are true i want to hear
the president answer
that question because we saw it during
the joint session
to congress where you have the president
walk in with a mask on to get to the
podium to take the mask off
and everybody else including the house
speaker and the vice president behind
him
are both wearing masks despite everybody
being vaccinated
and what we're seeing now what you're
not seeing in media reports is that
vaccinations
while they were going up for months
rising steadily
in the past two weeks we are seeing a
drop now in terms of the number of
vaccinations that are being administered
and i wonder if it's because of the
optics that you're seeing there on the
screen
where lawmakers who swear that the
vaccine works and swear that you should
go out and get it
continue to wear mass when the cdc to
your point earlier
says it is perfectly safe in indoor
settings if everybody is vaccinated
not to wear a mask so optics matter and
this president and this vice president
and this speaker of the house simply do
not get it thank you joe concha
uh good luck on that show you deserve it
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else